let's do one more thing here that sort
of i guess captures this whole thing i
mean biden is just losing it he just is
it's a sad depressing reality we can all
joke about it all the time and i do and
then my mom always says stop joking
about it so much because it's actually
quite sad he's the pilot of the plane
and the pilot is clearly incapable uh
here he is yesterday when he uh thought
he was just gonna freely take some
questions
and i'll be now happy to take your
questions since there's so many people
out there i'm gonna been given a list
now how about chris or the associated
press first question
mr president
so they hand him a list we don't know
who they is and then when other people
try to ask him questions they get pushed
away and rushed away i'm fairly certain
if this was the orange guy the media
would be screaming about it
carol it's it's depressing right like we
don't whether you like the guy or not
whether you think that they're trying to
usher in the new world order or not this
isn't the way it's supposed to be
right whether you like him or not is
irrelevant here because i i think we
need to hear from our president you
don't have to agree with him you don't
have to disagree with him uh we need to
hear him speak we need to hear him talk
to the american people and again every
time he talks to us he says something
crazy and we're all like wait what
but in general we don't hear from him
that often and the fact that he only
goes to media that is his preferred
media people you know i don't know i
don't know who chris at associated press
is but but that chris said associated
press should know that he's being chosen
because they think that he's going to be
um you know kinder to biden or or just
softer
if i'm chris i i i don't think that
looks particularly great for me that
they're confident i'm not going to ask a
difficult question and throw the
president off his game liz did you
happen to see the other part in this
speech we should have grabbed the clip
where he goes again in on the very fine
people hoax and he says that you know
this is why he decided to run for
president because trump said there were
very fine people in charlottesville and
we know and i've debunked it a million
times and all the internet conspiracy
theorists have done the same thing where
trump immediately did condemn the white
supremacists and the neo-nazis but that
biden is just repeating lies that are
put in front of him he doesn't know what
he's saying and i just don't know what
to do at this point
well it's interesting i i did a whole
episode on my show last week about this
trifecta of i called it this trifecta of
evil that's happening in our country
where we have corrupt politicians who
don't want to be held accountable to
their voters they're doing things like
what hunter biden did they're doing
things like uh trying to spend our money
like with the modern monetary theory i
don't need to give you an example of all
the corrupt things they're doing we have
corrupt politicians we all understand
that but the reason they're able to get
away with their corruption is twofold
it's because we have big tech that's
censoring reality they're censoring any
information that would expose the
corruption right they're creating this
information vacuum by saying nope if you
if you if you send a link about hunter
biden we are going to actively stop you
from doing that because we don't want
you to hear about this story and then in
this vacuum of information that they've
created then the mainstream media comes
in and they propagate lies they're not
the censors they're the ones who are
telling you actually now that we have
the truth out of the way here's what we
want you to believe and it's only
because of this trifecta these three
these three parts of this apparatus that
corrupt politicians are actually able to
get away with their corruption otherwise
we would find out and we would never
stand for it this would be a bipartisan
rejection of this kind of corruption
that that's what we see with the story
about charlottesville this this very
fine people narrative from the left we
we know empirically what the truth is
this is not a controversial thing to say
you can look up the video yourself
trump actually said except for white
supremacists and neo-nazis like he was
not talking about them who i condemn
totally big tech sensors conservative
yeah he condemned them totally he did
and he did it again and again and big
text censors conservatives who who try
to tell the truth and then the
mainstream media comes in with with
their false narrative and that's what
people believe the only reason biden is
able to get away with his corruption and
lies is because of big tech and the
mainstream media that's why he calls on
these people because they are a critical
part of his apparatus
carol as someone that works at the post
and fox and a columnist and journalist i
mean do you remember when it really went
so haywire with so many of your
colleagues or so many of the people at
uh these other organizations
you know i think it is
trump i think that was the moment where
they lost it where they no longer even
pretended to see themselves as some
arbiters of truth they became um
you know anti-trump as as a position and
as a job i remember brian stelter
working this out kind of publicly and
saying like are we supposed to like
um you know fact check trump in real
time are we supposed to uh ask questions
that we know he's gonna you know not
tell the truth to but as if that's only
limited to trump right they're not
backing anybody else so it became like
our mission is no longer
uh to be journalists where i you know i
i liberal media has always been a thing
it's not like that's new it's not like
they've um
just began pushing their positions but i
think what changed is the openness with
which they do it and the way that they
have changed their
entire focus it's it's really no longer
about telling american people the truth
it's about telling american people the
story that they think that american
people need to hear right and by the way
it's like you got to sort of admire the
machine to your point liz because they
can get away with the lies because then
there's big tech and the machinery that
we're always playing catch up and trying
to whack them all of the lies we're all
running behind that we do need a little
bit of a paradigm shift which is my
final question which is uh you guys know
how i try to do this show i try to give
people at the end especially on a friday
like the vision of the positive vision
of how we get through this thing and how
we make some sense of it and how as i
know you guys both as friends you can
live good happy lives in the in in the
midst of this lunacy liz how can we do
it
uh well i mean i i say this
tongue-in-cheek in a sense because i am
myself obsessed with politics of course
but make sure that you have your
perspectives in proper order i mean you
should be spending time with your family
you should be spending time with your
spouse you should be having children you
should be going to church you should be
having a community you should be
pursuing hobbies you should be doing
things for enjoyment you should be
partaking in charity i mean all of these
things i mean i i know i sound like a
preacher at this point but all of these
things are the joy of life the reason
that that we're in politics the reason
that we're in political commentary the
reason that we're in media is to protect
those things now so often we have so
much passion for what we do that we get
i should speak for myself here i get
obsessed with it i i'm a workaholic by
nature because i love what i do but i i
have to make sure that i don't lose
sight of those things because um those
are the joys of life so what i do on the
weekend is i spend time with my husband
i spend time with my daughter i spend
time with my family and my friends and i
i do the things that we are fighting to
protect and so i like i said i know this
sounds cliche it sounds cheesy but this
is this is what we as conservatives have
to remember to do it also helps us order
what we need to protect politically
based on what we want to do with our
families